that men on Batman speaking of which I
the defenders I've seen the first three
episodes of have you real
I have holy [ __ ] alright I know they had
the panel yesterday and all majors and
they showed number one they showed the
one episode they weren't even supposed
to but they're like one maybe they were
planning it but they were like we're
going to show you an old episode and the
reaction on Twitter was massive people
seem to dig it you've seen three
episodes I've seen - it says 75% of that
show is awesome unit you know the one
part that's not awesome Sigourney Weaver
no her pantsuits are amazing but I know
it's every time the story said I'd like
swerves away from over the lawyer who's
fighting his hidden past and doesn't
want to give in to his violent urges and
the drunk private investigator who's
trying to put a life back together in
the ex-convict who gets out of jail and
just wants to feel coffee with Claire
and that happens it's like as soon as he
goes off the [ __ ] bus well then
there's this other guy and the rest and
every time that other dude shows up
you're like I don't want any of this
with you you made it through all of iron
fist and I did I did two Egyptian doing
yeah it took a minute it took a minute I
wasn't like by the end of it I wasn't as
some people like come on now hey man we
got an iron fist we're on our way we're
one step closer the defenders and
there's some cool [ __ ] there Colleen
wing was really [ __ ] cool seeing
Claire get a lot more screen time was
really cool and I saw Seraphin I'm not
supposed to spoil anything to the
embargoes like the 24th of July but
that's what like Monday yeah you're
right so [ __ ] it we're fine yeah and I'm
not gonna go cheap because you don't
want deep there are never does these are
just the tip kind of guy look i'm
surface area I'm not digging tunnels I'm
just but there's a scene at the end of
episode 2 where it gave me a thing I
didn't know I wanted as bad as I wanted
it when Luke Cage beats the [ __ ] out of
Iron Fist oh really
yeah it's kind of awesome
first my you know instantly I want to be
like why they're supposed to be friends
but I'm sure make nobody starts his
friends oh really
ever that time we beat the [ __ ] out of
each other here and be true friends as
how we became bread [ __ ] around then
we were like let's defend people and
then and then at the end of episode
three you get and you've seen this unit
trailers we're all for them are fighting
together yeah and that's [ __ ]
transcendent but you got to endure a
decent amount of iron fist to get there
I'm just saying you're getting iron
fisted before the good stuff what hours
to go any Weaver and who is she anybody
from Marvel Comics or no not that I can
tell so far but she's you know ominous
pants she's like evil Hillary Clinton
will they making this at the hoping for
different results or something or no I
mean it would have been helpful well for
Humanity hub is she in control of like
the Hannah's handbag do you want to know
well I mean they saw the trailer and
Electra's in it so I had to assume the
hand plays a part
it does indeed and stick shows up those
stickers in the truck eat better show
yeah he was in the [ __ ] teasers are
you guys are [ __ ] down a beautiful
Gator Judah cotija New York be super
friend look you there's the line in the
trailer where he's like I don't want any
super friends and something like that is
that did you see that part had now that
my second I was in the trailer made me
left it was a Luke Cage like I'm not
looking for any Super Friends there it
is a decent amount of a lap right there
man but there's a decent amount of
everybody like not understanding and
calling [ __ ] on like I'm the
immortal Iron Fist but what the [ __ ] is
that I'm the guard in the Kunlun
[ __ ] it's all of that it's kind of
great that sounds a lot like Jessica
Jones doing a lot of that yeah everybody
does it because it's the dumbest [ __ ]
idea of it nom I channeled my Chi and
and one part of my body glows and I
punched through things with it not
everything because again you could iron
fists all the time if you have total
control of your Chi just [ __ ]
everything gets iron fisted but now
got me angry or committed does he need
he needs time to recharge on the TV show
he did right because I remember at one
point that's what he needs to do like
this is how I recharge Oh give you like
20 minutes why do you think my piss mate
iron
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]